やあ、みんなドガンここにいるよ。これは
新しいオフィスだ。新しいオフィスでの最初のビデオだ。驚くべきことだ。家
について多くの質問を受けて
いる。一番の質問
は、なぜ特定の場所で天井がこんなに低いのかということだ。
私のオフィス、私の
スタジオ、家の残りの部分の間のトランジション スペースに行き、
それに答えるのが好きです。
いくつかのスペースで非常に低い
理由は、天井が低いエリアを通過すると
、
低い天井のないエリアと
高い天井のエリア
は、実際よりもはるかに広々としているように感じます
私がここにいる時間の 99 時間は、
このドアから私のオフィスに歩いている
ところです 小さな机のようなものがあります
ここで何か仕事ができるかもしれないし
、日本語の本のようなものをここに置いてもいいけど
、このエリアに2、3分以上立っていることは決してないだろうし、
このようなスペースを通り抜けると、
少し意図的に窮屈な
とき 天井がずっと高いオフィスに入ると、
この
天井は
実際よりもずっと高く感じますこれは実際には
伝統的な日本の建築からのデザインの一種の手がかり
です私が
理解している方法は、古い日本の
家屋だったのではないかと思います
チェスト、茶室、
これらの非常に低い窓、非常に
低いドアがあり、サモデーサムライ
が剣を持って部屋に簡単に入ることができなかったので、身
を
かがめて中
に入る必要があり、一種のセキュリティ
対策であり、 その副産物は、
あなたがしゃがんでいたときに何が起こるかであり、
最終的にそれを通り抜け
て部屋に入ると、部屋
が実際よりもはるかに大きく感じられたので、
これについての私の理解は一種のもの
になりました
特定の場所の伝統的な日本建築の日本建築の定番 長い間い
ない特定の場所
は少し窮屈に感じます
婉曲表現を使用するのは居心地が良いかもしれません
。あなたが行く場所に着くと
、あなたが
長い間いる部屋は実際よりもはるかに大きく感じ
られます。この種の低い天井には例外が1つあります。 限ら
れた期間だけ天井の低い場所にあり、
それがこの
部屋ですこれはゲストルーム
ですここの天井が低い理由は
実際には建築基準法な
ので天井が高くなるとスペース
が増えます 部屋として扱われます
が、一定の高さ以下の場合、そのスペース
はモノキとして扱わ
れます。一種の収納スペースのようなもの、
または
屋根裏部屋のようなものかもしれませ
ん。 それについて
、
ここでは天井を低く保つことで、日本の家の総表面積をどのように規定するかを規定する法律の範囲内にとどまることができました。
なぜなら、これはゲスト
ルームだから
です。 ほとんど
ただ寝ている
ヤバダンさんと一緒にビデオを撮影していることを
知っていますか、クリスや他の
YouTube仲間のように出てき
てここにとどまります。私
たちは大きな部屋で撮影
します。 私のオフィス
での撮影では
、中庭のさまざまな場所で撮影する予定です。
この部屋は、主
に夜
起きて寝るためのもの
です。
家 私はそれが万人向けではないことを知ってい
ますが、モデルハウスで同じ
建築原則が適用されているのを見て
、説明を聞いたとき、
それは本当にクールだ
と
思いました。
材料費などについて、近い将来、家についてもっと多くのビデオを作成
することがどのように判明したか、質問がある場合は、お気軽に
下にコメントを残して
ください。